foreign
what's going on in your world Jamie
hi so glad to talk to you guys thank you
so much absolutely
my my question is
are
are we too old and are we dreaming too
big too late and the reason why I say
this is because I have been binge
watching and listening to where
everything Ramsey for the last week and
I went from gazelle focused totally
excited to Absolute fear because we have
absolutely nothing absolutely nothing we
have eight kids we've already failed the
oldest three although I hope to be able
to teach them these things too but we
still have six younger ones
um and I like everything in me I've I
haven't heard anybody with like our our
place and um I feel like I'm Gonna Fill
the budget I've never done one before in
my life I'm just kind of like um I'm a
stay-at-home mom and homeschooler so I'm
kind of like are we too old are we too
late is this gonna happen how old are
you because you see energy of a 17 year
old
oh thank you um I'm 40 I'll be 42. oh my
gosh
how are you still alive you're a newborn
baby you should run for president you're
so old
who told you you were old Jamie who told
you that it was too late for you she's
at home with these kids she is feeling
it right now that's what it is these
kids are running her ragged
well because I feel like I failed our
older three already we can't help them
pay for any education whatsoever
hold on hold on hold on hold on I've
heard you say the word fail too many
times in this short period of time and I
want you to stop saying that
okay nobody talks to our friend Jamie
like that yeah especially not Jamie
exactly stop using that word fail
because life we're learning out here
we're learning also there's like a 75
year old listening right now who's
offended that you said you're old okay I
know that's right I'm sorry 275 year
olds let's roll this thing out because
we the the goal is for us to debunk
everything that you've just all the
fears that you've just laid out so let's
look at the finances here you got eight
kids what's the household income
I worry about 55 right now I'm currently
looking for a job and doordashing trying
to add as much income as I can while
still being able to be at home I mean
daycare is way too expensive for me to
go out and get outside job okay so how
much is the debt that you guys are
facing
yeah 58 000 58 000. what kind of debt is
it give us the breakdown
uh we have 17 for across seven credit
cards we have a 7 800 car note five
thousand medical and my stupidity 27
000 in student loans
how much in student loans again sorry I
was writing all that down you know
twenty seven thousand twenty seven
thousand student loans all right I
thought you were gonna say a lot more
debt than what you said so I'm glad that
it's 58k because look here's the thing
it could be worse it could be a lot
worse your girl talking to you right now
I paid off 460 000 in the income at the
time when we started with 30 000. so
when I tell you all things are possible
all things are possible and it might
require you it probably is going to
require you to pick up some extra work
whenever you can find it and I'm not
going to sit over here and act like I
know when that is because you've got
eight kids and I've got two so whatever
that looks like for you and your husband
there's you if you want to get this done
quickly you do need to increase your
income and you can start thinking about
ways that you could do that but in the
meantime you've been listening to us for
the past few weeks we're going to tell
you what we tell everybody else to do
you got to walk through these baby steps
thing one is you gotta get that thousand
dollars saved I don't know if you've
done that yet but put aside a thousand
dollars most people can get it done in
30 days if they're selling things going
scorched Earth and the kids let them
know we're eating noodles with butter
this month like that's what that's on
the menu okay and so that's what that
looks like and then we're gonna do we're
gonna work this debt through this debt
snowball we're gonna list them smallest
to largest not by interest rate balance
only smallest to largest so your
smallest balance looks like it's this
medical debt right the 5K uh or is it a
baby credit card
it's a baby cry we have like a two 700
to 1700 so good you'll knock those out
real fast yeah it seems like that is
definitely possible we don't have any
money outside of the Thousand I feel
like you do
no we have nothing nothing at all
anything you can sell just a thousand
oh no
throughout you know four or five low
um cost things to sell but other than
that not really okay what's he doing for
work
um he's a city he works for a city
locating utilities under the ground oh
okay yeah
um and I hope I mean I've I've been
looking for jobs like crazy and I'm
hoping to be able to at least add up to
20 000 a year yes from the jobs that
I've been able to find so I mean I'm no
stranger to work yeah that's incredible
I think if you can do that you've got to
do that and you know I take I've taken
this question a couple of times even on
my Instagram you know sometimes dealing
with single moms or people who are
really just at the brink and it's like
okay there does come a point where it's
like you're doing all that you can
you've taken all the extra jobs it
doesn't make sense to do this because of
daycare there does come a point where
it's like okay I'm bringing in what I
feel like is the amount of money and
then you just gotta ride it out man that
at some point it's like I've just gotta
ride the train until I get to the stop
and sometimes it is like that I do think
you can get your income up more
um but you might not you might not be
making 150k when this all shakes out you
might be at 80 or you might be at 90 but
keep going down that field and keep
pushing forward because you might you
might get your income up more than what
you ever thought possible but here's the
thing the time is going to pass so we've
got to keep going hard we've got to keep
being intense about this and it might
not go as fast as you want it to go you
guys have eight kids and that's a choice
that yeah you know that you yeah you've
got to deal with and so yeah it's about
finding ways to get that income up
getting the expenses down and just walk
through this snowball and at the end of
the day not taking on any more debt
drawing that Line in the Sand and saying
this is it I'm not borrowing any more
money my husband and I took us seven and
a half years Jamie to pay off our debt
so I this this might be a journey for
you but it's a journey worth going on
because at the end of the day like I
said the time is going to pass so go on
the journey and go on the ride and get
this debt paid off are you guys using a
budget
yeah
um I for the first time in my life I've
I did April which was the lost cause
that I was just trying to look and see
what happened in April and find money
and so I'm working on the May one to get
that going is he on board with this this
feels like a Jamie plan so far
yeah it definitely started with me um
but I have been trying to
um tell him our why and he is definitely
getting on board more each day good well
I'm gonna make it easier for you we're
going to gift you Financial Peace
University for one year as well as every
dollar premium but I'll leave you with
this the best time to plant the tree was
30 years ago the second best time to
plan it is today you can do this channel
thank you you got this thank you thank
you
thank you I actually really love that
quote
it's not too late but we got to stop
looking to the past that's right into
the future and you're not a failure
you'll never get anywhere with that kind
of language and that's for any of y'all
listening be nicer to yourself and give
yourself some Grace out here